voice of the Bay Area sports since 1973
back here on the show how you been
Raymond so you want to am I an eagle to
me which means your show has already
spiraled out of control
you're not right we're just trying to
keep it on the rails it's all we're
gonna do what was the you clearly failed
here what was the first event you
covered in the Bay Area oh dear God
come on what do you got I do believe it
was a meaningless Giants game against
the Cardinals remember was planned
pitching starting managing all that
managing now I mean just no just it was
it was a game they just shut me out okay
so did you ever did you ever interview
Finley Charlie Finley do you ever ever
need contact with him a couple of times
fleetingly never one-on-one because
usually he did his stuff by phone and
usually with the beat writers or on
occasion when he really wanted to get
annoyed he would talk to the colonists
in Oakland a guy named Ron Bertrand who
who was as good as they get okay knew
had it knew how to punch families
buttons well he was really good well he
had buttons to push the old owner of the
Oakland Athletics
so um ray let's let's hit on the Raiders
real quick here right off the top
is it possible Marshawn Lynch is not
done playing and the Isaiah Crowell
injury to his Achilles means that we may
still get Marshawn Lynch one more time
for the Raiders this year I'd be
surprised because the point of having
Marshawn Lynch is using him and I don't
know that Jon Gruden wants to use him
anymore I mean is that that was sort of
made clear before and I'm not sure that
the Jon Gruden goes back I mean I think
in general he you know he leaves
scorched earth behind it and goes
forward at least that has been the the
mo the second time in Oakland when he's
got complete freedom of movement so I'm
guessing not I mean it's an interesting
a lot but it's largely an interesting
thought for
static reasons if they wanted Marshawn
Lynch back they would have they would
have made this happen before now and I
think they sort of made it clear when
they when they got CRO L and then
drafted the way they did that they'd
moved on and I don't know that they
moved back well I mean Josh Jacobs is a
really special player from Alabama who
they were able to get down in the 20s
and then went with Cleveland Farrell at
the top of the draft and I I kind of
think that may ox been hittin this thing
out of the park from acquiring Antonio
Brown to drafting the way that he
drafted to handling his business in a
manner that first time general managers
might stumble I wonder what you think
well first of all my sense is that Jon
Gruden does the directing and Mayock
doesn't heavy lifting and I think Mayock
was brought in to be the detail guy but
john bruton has his vision and he
doesn't want to be bothered with well
the procedure stuff so I think if you're
gonna say Matt you've got to say you've
got to take Gruden first in the same way
that when you say John Lynch
you have to say Kyle Shanahan first one
guy has the vision the other guy is the
one who's supposed to find the
ingredients so that the visionary can
make the meal secondly I don't know if
he had to hit it out of the park because
on the one hand I hate draft nerds
because they always talk about you know
perceived value within the draft and yet
I don't know what those guys are going
to be useful players for them just
because you don't know if anybody is
going to be a useful player for anybody
especially on a bad team because one
injuries and two bad teams tend not to
function well so that good players can
get wasted so I'm not making a judgment
on any of them yes I mean they they were
interesting picks because you know the
you know the nerd punditry said oh they
got those guys too early but that that
argument ends the day the draft ends
because
at that point it doesn't matter anymore
well I mean my answer to you is a firm
beats me
okay well I guess in drafts that that is
the case you know but to me you know the
question about whether you took Farrell
too soon
if Mayock had been pounding the table
for that guy sitting next to me from the
combine all the way through the draft
and teams didn't take him and then they
took him somewhere in the tens or 15s
they thought well it's a great value
coming here in mike Mayock talk about it
but he actually makes the pick as a real
general manager and people wondering if
he knows what he's doing well we'll find
out if we knows if he knows what he's
doing I mean that's the thing it's I
don't need to make the snap judgment on
him
I can wait until the things he does
right actually go on a field and
function so I'm not not hurry all right
so what about the 49ers drafting of Nick
Bosa and in him showing up with a lot of
his social media cleanse of political
stances that that might run counter to a
lot of people in the San Francisco
community ray I wonder what you think
about the fit there right off the top of
the Saxa quarterback I think he learned
a valuable lesson which is not to tell
people what he thinks and I know that
everybody says oh you know you people
respect you when you're when you're
honest and forthright no they don't they
want to hear what they want to hear so I
think he figured out or his agent figure
that for him or the 49ers helped him
figure out that he's paid per sack not
per concept what 49er fans will think is
it plays really good will look the other
way if he's not we'll bring it up I mean
it's you know you you move the battle
lines as it helps you best so and I
think for the most part people who would
find his tweets offensive by and large
are not that keen on football anyway so
I think all he really did here was
narrow the market to 49 or true
believers who will evaluate him on
whether he can save a defense that never
picked up a loose ball all year last
year and never bothered a quarterback
longer term I mean your your respected
to the extent that your batting average
says you are a really good player people
will find a way to rationalize
everything else if he's not they will
bring it up and hit him over the head
ray Ratto joining us from the Bay Area
right here on the Rich Eisen show Steve
Kerr's greatest concern as he's maybe
sitting in a hotel room in Houston
waiting for Saturday's game 3 preparing
for Saturday's game 3 is what that he
can figure out how to straighten out
Stefan Curry's finger I think of the the
Golden State's biggest problem this year
has been competing with itself and by
that I mean when they're not fully
engaged they show that but if you can't
be fully engaged when you're in the
playoffs against the team you hate the
most then you have a motivational
problem that a coach can't fix so I
think I think kurz worries today center
around Stefan Curry's finger and whether
he is ready for whatever new wrinkle
Mike D'Antoni can throw at him because
D'Antoni is the guy working with a the
limited roster and be the players who
they they really need you know a hundred
percent plus from and haven't been able
to get yet I mean Eric Gordon has been
okay PJ Tucker's been a very good
defender but Clint capela can't you know
you know they can't work the LOB with
him they've had a real hard time with
that they guarded hard and really well
and let's face it Houston at its best in
Golden State at its best is not a fair
fight so Houston has to be better than
it can possibly be and Golden State has
to be significantly worse and so far
that has what about the number of
minutes that his starters have been
playing and and just the fact of wear
and tear tread mental fatigue
potentially just after year after year
after you the same stuff we talked about
with LeBron and why a lot of people
thought that the Lakers should have
deactivated him sooner rather than later
because of all the extra seasons
combined that he has played through the
playoffs anything you think Kerr is
looking around and seeing the way that
the Clippers almost got him in that game
seven war of attrition before Durant
took things over with that 50 piece ring
I think their view point is that they
deserve to lose Game two because they
stopped to play and Game five they
didn't play well enough for long enough
I believe that they believe that when
they are fully engaged and you can tell
that right away by how they defense when
they are fully engaged no one can beat
them so I think when they lose they
rationalize that into well we weren't
really we didn't really see seize the
moment
I think against Houston they want to
seize the moment because truth be told
they don't like Houston Houston doesn't
like them and if he won't motivate you
then you know maybe they should put a
mirror under your nose to see if you're
still be able to fog it up few more
minutes left here all right I think for
them it it's just tactical stuff it's
not motivational and they get in trouble
when they forget to be motivated and
then his boogie cousins a possibility
should they get past Houston how real is
that I don't hear I think so you know I
mean conceivably but I don't know why
they would want to rush you unless they
got to like a game five and they're down
3-1 but even at that you still be
getting a guy who's not game shake right
and you know and to me I think one and
I'm not a doctor so I don't have to do
the injury is but I think there's not
much upside to rushing him back and I
think at this point they believe that
between the death line up between the
few minutes that Bogut can give them the
surprising stuff they've gotten from
Caban Looney I think they think they can
get by without them unless there's a
real crying need when they get to the
final I don't see it a couple more
minutes left with Ray Ratto
the Sean Miller story coming out of a
federal court that it appears he paid
DeAndre eight and ten thousand dollars a
month to play basketball for Arizona to
me in past years it would seem like that
would be a huge scandal that would lead
this show and many other shows and I'm
seeing in many ways a collective shrug
despite the fact that it's on top of
sports stack news stacks online in
various outlets I'm wondering what you
think right you know what I think we are
and take it from me I know this subject
we are a far more cynical nation than we
were five years ago and I think the
reaction to the story is not a shrug but
more of a duh you know I think people
think well of course they pay them you
know you know it why would you think
otherwise people outside like the the
deepest inner sanctums of college
basketball believe the sport is
incredibly dirty in terms of players
being paid and the viewpoint from there
dovetails in one of two ways one well of
course they should be paid they're the
ones doing the work or no they shouldn't
be paid but we know they get paid
because the people who are on college
sports basically operate in a you know
in a money-based economy like everybody
else does so I think the reaction to the
Miller stuff is more yeah I think we
figured that out already now tell us
what you're going to do about it and I
think at least in the case of Sean
Miller what they're going to do about it
is fire and then we'll see what the NC 2
a does about that but the undercurrent
of this entire story is that this is
what the NCAA deserves because it
doesn't believe that labor shouldn't be
free and so whatever embarrassment that
industry can endure is good because you
can't make a compelling argument that
players who do bring in that much money
shouldn't get something more than a
stipend
and you know I think that's where we are
as a country now and I think that's why
your your you're sensing a shrug it's a
really more of a well of course they're
getting paid and finally somebody caught
one guy now this college basketball
going to do something about it they just
gonna operate the way they always write
thanks for the time
always appreciate our chats let's chat
down the line yeah give my love to iron
you got it I will that's right right Oh
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app